on Friday Donald Trump slammed
Nordstrom's department store for
dropping his daughter Ivanka's clothing
line ok he slammed them and as a result
Nordstrom's stock price rose by almost 7
percent apparently apparently getting
slammed by the president on Twitter is
good for business so now companies that
have nothing to do with Ivanka Trump are
trying to cash in on this new formula
take a look at this ad after Donald
Trump was elected president we here at
Radio Shack heard you loud and clear
you didn't want the Trump business to
benefit from the Trump presidency
neither do we
that's why starting today RadioShack
will no longer sell Trump products in
our stores or on our website this
high-end a bunka Trump 3/8 inch 24
thread CB antenna back into the shredder
please to watch Melania Trump do loop
UHF VHF Universal rabbit ears thrown in
a fire and this Eric Trump grid style
printed circuit board with 2,200 Eric
Trump holes fed to an alligator
you don't like it president Trump come
at us preferably on Twitter
we're RadioShack and we need customers
I don't do this up I do want to
apologize for that alligator that was
the that's the shittiest thing I've seen
you've paid a lot of money to be here
and these people bought the nipple seats
we pull crap like that
you